[Music]
we're gonna break his record right now
show this kid what's up
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
hey babe hey
babe hey
babe hey buddy hey bubs how you doing
let me tell you something right now yeah
let me tell you something right now tell
it now
i just had the best tuna melt
yeah i've ever had in my entire life
is that true no literally dude because
we're more unsure
if you should order it the best tuna
melt i've ever had in my entire life it
was on an english
muffin yeah that's the english shout out
the english muffin is there a better
piece of bread
is there store-bought is there better
you want to fill up the nooks and
crannies you're going to fill them up
with an english muffin
the problem with eating the tuna melted
english muffin as i just did
yeah i didn't have enough points on my
fitness app
to eat it tuna melts gonna blow that out
of the water so i lo
now you by the way speaking of that real
quick you were astounded that i said i'm
trying to lose weight and i said i'm i'm
having 2 800 calories a day
you were you said that's crazy does not
compete or lose a pound
it doesn't compute that does not compute
how much do you weigh
roughly you're gonna make me say it no
no don't don't but no i'm kidding 235.
okay so so what i read was you should be
having under 2 350 calories
right whatever your weight is yes to
lose weight that's what i
read but also 2800 is bonkers bro
2000's you daily recommended i know
you're a tall dude you're a big guy
you're a classy gal i know all that
stuff but like
but i think 2 800 is a lot so here we go
we got the calorie calculator to
maintain weight 3084
let me tell you something with after my
eating today the weight was maintained
2834 mild weight loss half a pound a
week
one pound a week weight loss 2584
extreme weight loss two pounds a week
2084.
wait but what but but this is what body
type
i i just put in his weight and oh his
weight okay oh so there you go so 2800
is a mild weight loss a week for you
you go mild half a pound a week wow so
you can eat 3084 calories a day
and you'll just stay your weight that's
right so i'm gonna
just stay my way to but this is assuming
you're not exercising at all i would
imagine right so that would be me
no this is with mild exercise with mild
god oh my god what if you're sedentary
yeah i
extreme weight loss 2084 if you
if you made yourself eat 2 084 calories
a day
for you that would be ext in the bracket
of extreme weight loss i would say
2084 calories is what two tuna melts was
the one tuna amount the tuna melt i had
does that have
instead of having fries i did have
sauteed spinach but then i had five
garlic stuff you had steamed spinach
don't beat yourself up
sorry sorry sorry steamed spinach is
like 30 calories
but then i did have five garlic sticks
with cheese garlic sticks that i dipped
in vodka sauce yeah you're you're
you're at like 5 000 calories how many
is one garlic cheese stick with vodka so
well that was a generous portion i saw
that there's a lot of cheese on that
my guess is one of those strips is 200
calories and i had five of them
no you didn't yeah and i dipped them all
in vodka sauce i had the most
you didn't have any i think i think one
i would say minimum 150 on each of those
how many garlic sticks did you have one
you had one how many do you have
and i had five so what's wrong with me
no nothing it was a delicious food
and and you're not in bad shape i am i
don't want to eat five
oh but okay but here's the thing let's
just be honest i mean i'm gonna say i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell
you box i'm gonna tell them something
personal and you could cut this out if
you want to cut out you had sausage and
peppers
i did a hero and that's a personal
statement i'm sorry that i i know we're
friends and you trust me the thing is
people tell the fans you had a sausage
and peppers
i was tired of what we normally order
and i wanted to throw a curveball i did
gut the bread and i toasted it not the
toasting has anything to do with it but
just so you know a little warm up about
my question to you and this may
i may be coming off like i'm trying to
feel better about myself and don't take
it that way but do you think
you eating a sausage and peppers hero
with the bread scooped out lightly
toasted
and me having me having a tuna melt on
me having a two month
english muffin with steamed spinach not
sauteed and five garlic sticks dipped in
vodka sauce
at the end of the day yeah did we
consume the same calories at dinner
or you're saying i definitely had more
regardless i feel like
uh it might have been close but those
garlic sticks those cheese garlic sticks
put you way over the top
yeah you know because yeah you're right
dude one is a wash that means you had
four in it though let's put them at four
together
i bet you had about seven to eight
hundred calories oh i'm not even
including the vodka sauce
let me ask you a question go ahead did
you polish it was the vodka sauce left i
did a dip of the vodka sauce i had half
the vodka sauce
vodka sauce is not good it's heavy cream
and i didn't calculate it in the fitness
palate
no you didn't know and then but to me if
i don't put in the fitness pal app it
doesn't count
what else did you eat today for
breakfast yeah
egg white egg avocado smash eggs avocado
on on a little dainty uh
uh wheat bread dainty a ziggy's yogurt
with chia flax seeds okay
then i had a um i it's my same problem a
bite a bite of um apple crumb french
toast from rocco's and bay ridge
which is phenomenal french toast a i
mean a bite of itself a bite
nothing then i had keto cheese chips
that i had downstairs and a quest cookie
oh you did that yeah
yeah yeah but you get 2 800 right yeah
but
so it's not like i i've done i haven't
ingested 4 000 calories today it's not
like i've done that
i want to know how much that tuna melt
was you really just on the fitness
palette it said about 290.
i mean my friend listen to me
there's no way that was 290. you got an
open-faced tuna melt so you get the two
pieces of bread
first and foremost you did have an
english muffin let's say 100 calories
that's actually not bad at all okay 100
calories then you got the tuna the
tuna's got mayo generous portion scoop
on both i'm gonna put you at swiss
cheese
yeah the cheese and it has a slice on
both yeah let's say 70th slice 140 with
the bread is 240.
i'm digging i'm thinking the tuna with
the mayo though with the mayo on both
i'm going to say you're putting in at
least 400 for the tuna at least
so that's not too bad actually so now we
got you at five
640. i always round up i just do
700. were there any sides just it's just
the same spanish
okay so i'll give you the same search i
won't even count it wow yeah and a
pellegrino what do we have in pellegrino
no zero zero yeah because that was a
that was that was a
seltzer with lemon flavor not a lemon
pellegrino here's the issue here's the
big problem running into
tomorrow's going to be snowstorm yes
it's already established my daughter's
school is closed i've already been
texted by
my girl her mom my family to say
100 i must do this is to bring home
chocolate chip cookies to bake in the
oven raisinets and popcorn because it's
movie night and you're in trouble and
we're baking cookies eating popcorn and
raisinettes
for the big snow day coming tomorrow
we're in trouble so i'm not gonna be
able to get out of that
you're in trouble but this is what you
do how serious are you about your
fitness goals
and and and do you have a date that you
need to lose the weight by
because honestly you could fight you
could actually use this
as a teachable moment right and you can
go through the snowstorm
and be strict and then come out the
other end possibly having a newfound
rejuvenation
for your abilities and your and your and
you know your commitments
that being said right you could also
just you know
just eat your face off for three days i
was told because
you know we mentioned on the podcast
that i was gonna i'm hosting a true tv
show i was
told and asked by you know with the
people there if there was a way you know
can get down to like 220 would be great
and they told me that on the pilot
which i filmed four months ago when i
was 225 i said it's going to be no
problem to get to 220 i'm only 225. they
said great
this thing gets picked up at b220 the
issue is since the pilot to now i've
went up to 240.
so now okay and then thing starts in a
month yeah but hold on a second
they had the they they they really made
that request of you like it was
crazy it wasn't like you have to do this
it's like oh if you you know
cameron if you could get down you know 2
15 20 just be a lot better but isn't
most of your show you drinking beer
yeah that's the thing most of it's me
drinking beer and being
i i would i would have been appalled i
would have been
rightfully angry i think if someone told
like yeah you do you want to like wait
you're telling i'm gonna do i'm just a
i'm i'm a
i'm an adult i kind of said like i'm a
comedian and i've said on the show that
casting directors have told me i have
leading man face best friend body right
so like why
like let's just go with that wow wow
well what do they think people are going
to see if you're five pounds heavier
when they watch this i think she'll get
in season two
five pounds heavier so they're you're
they're trying to also tap into your
attractiveness
i think they are uh-huh but the
but but the demo for the show a bar in
your backyard is mostly probably
a gentleman your own age yeah most
likely so who
who are they trying to attract they're
trying to get a female component in on
this yeah i mean listen let's be i'm
proud to do the show but my show's going
to be background noise in the dentist's
office
no but you know how you know look you
know the tricks of the trade too it's
like we we love to eat like
you go to when we go to uh sometimes
you've done this too when you go to like
get food yeah right why don't we tell
people the life hack that you do here's
the live feed
listen to all of our fatty friends out
there i i do this when i go to a
mcdonald's or a pizza or anything when
i'm getting really hungry what i'll do
is
i'll go in with the intention of i all
the food is for me but what i'll because
i'm so genuinely embarrassed
of how much food i'm ordering i'll go to
like a mcdonald's drive-through
and i'll say you know can i get a number
two um let me get a big mac
order fries uh coke and apple turnover
and what did she say she wanted
what did she say she wanted um oh yes um
uh number three quarter pounder with
cheese uh hold the onions
there's something else i'm sorry but
she's pregnant you like to get yeah you
like me
that you're ordering for multiple people
just for you yeah i always go what did
you say she wanted
and i'll just i'll rub my eyes but
really it's just i'm buying time
my fingers bleeding again because i took
off your bandage i took off the band i
have blood on my forehead now
no but there's a red dot right here i
can't i think that's the blood from the
open wound
it might just look like a blemish oh no
that's because i cut my i cut i i
thought i unibrow yesterday i tried to
cut i tried to shave in between my
eyebrows and i cut open my eyebrows yeah
that's a whole nother cut
and i told you i shaved my eyebrows off
once by accident no you have not
that's a story for another day all right
well now it'll be a terrific time to
tell us oh that's right we're on the
podcast
now i remember when you told me that
that you did that because i died
laughing because i've done that in my
life
yeah i i've been like go go in and just
be like how would they say they need it
yeah oh and oh you know what and also
for um
another another uh junior bacon
cheeseburger
richard another trick i do is i'll order
i'll order
food i'll like go sit and again it's
literally this
it's just because i'm this hungry but
what i'll do is i'll go sit down
like at a restaurant at a diner
someone's meeting me uh no no i'll go
down i'll go sit down and i'll say you
know
you know just me i get a cheeseburger
french fries you know a malted
and um and you know you know an apple
pie or something like that
you know eat it all and be like oh and
can i also get
chicken fingers macaroni and cheese and
coke to go and then i'll eat that in my
car
yeah i've done that i've done that
multiple times yeah
people that don't eat like that i don't
know i get it though i i've been there
yeah no it's just like look dude it's
the same thing like you know addiction
to anything else with food but i mean
you know like look i'm telling you right
now that i'm
i you know you're you're saying that you
think i went over my calories i'm saying
i just made it to 2800
and we're going to agree to disagree
yeah but either way i'll probably have a
sleeve of oreos tonight
and not count it in the fitness app and
then wake up tomorrow and be like
why are my tits and belly button
jiggling i didn't go over my calories
so so wait wait wait wait
wait wait but you you're good you work
out you really do work out i do work out
i've been no i've been
i've been getting better i've been
getting tighter my body composition's
been changing but
it's literally the first time in my life
where like the last couple so the doctor
basically gave me the last
call they were like if you don't i have
to go back in april they were like if
you don't have
like normal cholesterol numbers and
blood pressure and like
then you're at your medication time wow
man so they were like that it's one it's
your choice okay so i said let me get
one more tuna melt
let's get the let's get the vodka sauce
one more time garlic cheese one more
time but what i'm doing is is now like
you know today's a sunday so i let it go
a little bit on sunday but
monday monday i it's the strictest i
ever am
is monday and then it's just like work
out hard eat right
tomorrow being a snow day may be tough
you know it's funny because the last
three weeks have been snow days
the day after we do this podcast yes the
snow in new york
you've never seen the show day after
tomorrow the movie day after tomorrow
that's what it is in new york right now
snow day go ahead favorite snow day
superstitions
put a spoon under your pillow never
heard of that in my entire life don't
know why you would do it yeah
put a spoon under your pillow and does
that help bring snow
kids like put a spoon because they want
a snow day flush ice cubes down the
toilet
don't do that but they do flush pajama
uh they do flush puppy dog pals down the
toilet
put your pajamas both backwards and
inside out put on your pajamas backwards
brush your teeth with your non-dominant
hand i don't understand these are snow
day superstitions in what capacity
yeah i don't understand i think this is
little kids wanting to get a snow day
i'll tell you this my daughter's five
years old her when we told her this
morning that the school had already sent
an email
saying that the school is closed
tomorrow it's like her super bowl
like she genuinely was like crying shout
out tom brady shout out to
the bucks yeah one who won the super
bowl or you know actually no
they didn't shout out patrick mahomes
and the chiefs chiefs
or what a what a doozy tie game
both the chiefs and the bucks won the
super bowl yeah so um
they um uh she literally like
fought falls on the floor like she can't
imagine
i don't know what's better like i wonder
if we should do a test
if i said to her or any child if i
you know put a camera in the room get
like a little microscopic blood
not microscopic get a little blood
pressure cuff test their blood pressure
i wonder what would be
more elicit more of an emotional
reaction from them if we said hey
tomorrow's a snow day yeah see how
excited they get or say hey
pack your bags we're going to disney
world oh
it's tough because to a child yeah i
know but you would think but to a child
a snow day it's just like and no
zoom either like the teacher
specifically said that like no zoomy
like we're not
because now this really let him go
because now on june with the with zoom
it's like there's really no reason for
kids to have snow days anymore
oh yeah you could just do it everybody
could just teach from zoom but they've
said with a snow day
even though zoom school's closed give
them some a little dose of actual life
yeah go out there and make snowmen go
crazy on a snow day yeah that's what
we're gonna do and it's it's tough to
eat clean on a snow day i mean
you get fat you feel like everyone gets
a pass dude let me see the question snow
days as a kid did you run right out
were you sleigh riding building snowmen
did you take advantage fully
you're putting on the whole outfit
running out there with the scarf and the
gloves and the mittens
no here's another thing about me no and
i don't feel bad about it and i'd love
to do this with my daughter
never in my life have i built a snowman
really
nope never did the carrot with the rocks
i never built i never had the desire
i wouldn't even know how to do it well
it's three balls stacked on top of each
other with a couple of buttons
and a carrot a couple twigs for the arms
maybe a scarf
i'm telling you you know it sounds
easier than it is
yeah i mean there it is i think it's
this thing to build a snowman the first
snowman ever drawn was jewish what does
that even mean
just so you know uncovered by bob
eckstein from his book
that's a jewish name the history of the
snowman the earliest known depiction of
snowman
sits in a manuscript of the book of
hours from 1380
1380 oddly anti-semitic drawing features
the jewish snowman melting near
fire jesus christ oh my god bob x dean
who are you
bobby jesus lord terrible one time he's
a historian
oh he's just reporting the facts the
white snow represents god's forgiveness
of our sins
wait this is what a snowman represents
the white stone represents god's
forgiveness of our sins the circular
snowballs
show the everlasting life god promises
us the carrot nose shows us that god has
given us the earth and all living things
that's a stretch
that's a stretch i mean anyone can make
up anything like that and you know what
honestly in 2021 with all that's been
going on and obviously to show support
for the people of color who listen to
this podcast and thank you so much is
i'm going to make sure that tomorrow the
snowman that i do build with my daughter
will be black i'm not gonna have a white
snowman
i've never seen one but god bless i'm
not gonna do a white snowman that's why
you do you never see a black squirrel
no i'm serious they exist they're rare
no
yeah but if you've seen a black squirrel
i was with my niece one time we were
walking up
like in like uh uh like somewhere in
like the
what does it matter what neighborhood
we're in flatiron and we're walking and
a black squirrel ran across the street i
swear to god i was like look that's a
black squirrel that's not common did you
ever see a black squirrel before and
she's like no i never did i'm like there
you go there's a black swirl and i swear
to god she was like
oh like so there's all the squirrels
besides the ones she goes here she goes
so i'll see a mexican squirrel
i know i blew the doors off of our fifth
grade class about uh asking how black
people
came about really because we were we we
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no that's a wild thing to
ask
no because we were learning the bible
and i remember one day i raised my hand
i used to do a bit on this i raised my
hand
and i said you know miss demarist i said
uh
uh adam and eve they were the first
people and she goes yeah and i go they
were white and she goes yeah and then i
was like hmm
and then she raised my hand again she's
like yes and i was like miss demaris if
adam and eve were white and they were
the first people
how do we have black people and
everybody in the class were just like
yeah they looked up from the everyone
even my black those the black friends
like everyone just looked up right away
i was like staring at and she's like
and then she goes okay okay she's like
well
well good question she goes the bible
you know is not necessarily meant to be
taken
literally so we're like what does that
mean she goes well
maybe not everything in the bible you
know the way you read it
actually happened the whole class was
like
what the [ __ ] what are you talking about
yeah
people it was a complete meltdown did
she quit complete no she was no she
didn't quit
but i mean it was a full-blown meltdown
yeah people like what about
no one in the ark what about this what
about that she's like yeah no no no no
people are like
well you can't just tell us there is for
all those years and then just take it
back [ __ ] destroyed you yeah
i mean everyone went home that day and
told their parents everyone just was
like
guess what yeah they're like yeah you're
like yo yo it's oh merry christmas jesus
birthday like is it mom
kirsty throw the toys back at her uh
dude one time
i i um was playing college basketball
division three so it's like it didn't
even count
but don't do that to yourself i
appreciate it nobody here played
division three i'm in the whole
of him didn't play i'm in the hall of
fame in my college did i ever tell you
that i think you might have told me that
on my school's all-time favorite but
it's division three so it's like almost
like i'm embarrassed to say it
yeah i swear to god yeah i told you when
i made the jv
uh when our when our school first got a
basketball team our catholic
grammar school cyo team right we were in
i think
seventh or sixth grade and they they
team for the first time so
they made the varsity team and you had
to have go tryouts and then i was like
no one was good i wasn't good and i
didn't make the team
and so i got slated first on jv
i just i kind of just missed the cutoff
on varsity right and i don't know
excuse me if i told this and i got
slaved on jv never had a team before
everyone who didn't make varsity just
got anyone could make jv right
right so every every other ragtag kid
got thrown on jv
my friend's mom who never coached
basketball really and didn't really know
it
was like i'll be the coach god love her
she learned like she really did she
learned about baseball she worked the
clipboard we were doing drills
but nobody was good nobody knew the
drills nobody remembered anything
and we went to go play oh i've told this
story on my other podcast before but
so end up end up the first game where
like we're nervous as [ __ ] no one's ever
played
an organized game before and we're like
oh you know
we're going to get slaughtered like what
is this team like in all honesty we're
like what are the teams
like all black kids from neighborhood
that plays basketball they're just
freaking dunking they're all told on us
they're all excellent
already we've never played before in
life we're gonna get demonstrated right
sure [ __ ] sure enough first and only
game
ever that i've ever played in cyo the
first team we played was 100
black kids they beat us 44 to nothing
you didn't score one point no 44 to
nothing is what they beat i told this
story in my pockets before it's actually
a little bit of a
popular story that i used to tell but
they beat us 44
they came out you know in the beginning
you're just doing layup drills and stuff
they were doing like work through the
leg back with layup drills a kid dunked
i'm not kidding around right
a kid was touching rim we were like i
was literally in sixth grade we were
like what are we gonna do
they beat us 44 nothing okay you know at
the end of the game when you line up and
you like shake hands in the middle
you're like good game good game good
game
and then usually a parent would have to
bring like juice and chips and then you
get juice and chips
right so at that point we're going good
game good game
i don't know if there was ever been a
shutout in basketball in anyone's lives
whether that's hard to do i'm a sure
professional whatever
well i will tell you this was like this
was playing like an nba final
it was them giving us a drubbing but
like the fact that they were about to
get a shutout
the place was teeming with excitement
they would they were screaming it was
like it looked like it was a
championship game
but it was just because they were about
to make history and shut out a
basketball team
like were you guys trying to take shots
we were trying the best that we could
and the parents were screaming and
yelling and people were
amped i mean even i think even some of
our parents were like this is amazing
don't score and then it ended and then
i don't know who started the chant but
the parents
and the children as you were shaking
hands were just screaming and yelling
and cheering and they started going
44 zip zip 44 zip and they just started
clapping
in our faces
i had a mother come right in my faces
closer she goes four to four
zip they dip just screaming at us and
then we shook hands and had to turn and
walk up the steps together in the
hallway
to go back up to the locker rooms where
you exchanged the juices and up the
steps echoing 44
zip parrots were just in our faces
screaming if the kids were screaming it
it was the most embarrassing thing i've
ever i mean i mean
i was i was mvp we went that whole year
i was mvp of the team we had an award
ceremony he got grouped in with the
other ceremony
mvp of the year 16 points really the
next game we've seen points for the
season the next game we played blessed
sacrament we lost 56-3
56-3 i had all three points though wow
yeah a field goal and a foul shot
56-3 we never even had a lead or
anything close to it until the dead last
game of the year
something finally snapped and went our
way we were like the 12th or the 14th
game whatever it was
and we just were playing and they were
going in like
it was going as like it should have gone
right and at the
half we looked up we were in the huddle
we looked up and someone goes
holy [ __ ] we're winning and it was like
you know like like 18
16. i'm like oh my god oh my god we lost
we lost we went uh we went on
one you're unfeeded
we didn't whatever the opposite of
undefeated is the one and only year who
played cyo basketball no
next year i was on the varsity team and
we won the championship okay i wasn't
good again and then but we still won but
we're going to see division
see because i thought you went i thought
you were going to say like you nev
you've technically never won a game in
cyber basketball which i would say well
then we have to sign you up and see why
basketball
dude 44 zip would resonate with me in my
dreams 44
i would lay down like because it was so
mortifying of course
yeah and i would hear like to this day i
mean that happened when i was in sixth
grade i was eleven
right so 33 years later i sometimes i'm
walking around going
44 zip zip forward yeah yeah like just
like they got right in off it
really learned what it meant to lose big
right there yeah you know what's weird
about that like little chance like that
that gets stuck in your head like for
some reason and i don't know why i do
this at all
like if there's like a moment of of like
just like i don't even want to say
calmness but like
it's stagnant in my mind or like i'm
doing a task that's like mundane
or when i get really nervous i don't
know why but in my head
just over and over starts to play in
sometimes i even like melted i'd go here
we go yankees here we go
yeah and i don't know why i go here we
go yankees here we go and i
what is that you think it takes me back
to like a happy place or
it's just like it's like a jingle it's
like those jingles of commercials like
if you name right now if i tell you
something from the 80s
you'll remember the jingle that's the
point of the jingle right it's to root
itself
somewhere deep in the recesses of your
brain
yeah the touch the feel of cotton yeah
the fabric of the glass
how about uh i don't know anything else
uh it's full just
there you go that's what it is there you
go juicy fruit
is gonna move yeah you know that one
eight seven seven
six four three four four four four four
five
eight what is that seven seven what is
that three
four four one eight hundred
m-a-t-t-r-e-s
there it is are those local new york
things give me a break
give me a break how about that one for
the new york state lottery i'm
yo london can i can you hand me can you
can you hand me that right there check
this out guys
we spoke about yolanda vega who is our
new york state lottery affiliate person
who draws the numbers
we spoke about her on a podcast that is
unreleased as of yet
and might come out later but she is our
basically our muse
and we love this woman on the podcast
would be a great guest we want to get
yolanda vega on this podcast we'd like
to maybe she could even do if you're a
friend
of your family with her we'd love to get
yolanda on yes if you're a friend or
family member of yolanda vega
this and if you don't know her since i'm
a young person
uh this is the woman who draws the new
york state lottery numbers
and she has a little calling card and
this is what she says
are you ready for this
isn't that amazing the best do you think
i love you do you think i love you too
do you think that
she came up with that or you think like
she was just on the air one day oh i've
shown a parent's name
uh no i think that she probably just i
don't know like she's a broadcaster in a
sense right she just did it so i'm
yolanda vega
if you're from new york there's nothing
that says new york as a bodega
she is as new that saying is new york
through and through
you can actually and probably at times
must be tough to be here because when
she walks she's the type of person
she's walking through the streets i
would say a hundred times a day
people are yelling yolanda vega yeah but
also she can't fault it
because it also is i mean that's what
gave her i wonder if she's like
like if she's making money because she's
the
person to draw the number like did she
get a cut of this yeah i mean i i know
i hope she did but like we googled this
yolanda vega we didn't see
we did we we did and this is going to
come out in another episode but we
looked her up and i said
cuban gymnast by the way oh yolanda vega
on cameo
well that makes total sense that makes
total sense if she's on cameo because
she's got to take lunch
everybody wants to hear it you should
pay five g's to get a yell on to vega
it's such a good name it is um
so one time i went to because we're
talking about snow i was just thinking
of this the other day one
on my uh old college basketball team
like group chatted
talked about this we were in vermont we
were playing i think
i forgot what school it was in vermont
but you know division iii basketball
maybe vermont
tech or something like that but anyway
there was a massive snowstorm
we played a basketball game in the
afternoon and then there was a massive
snowstorm that night and we were
supposed to play a team the next day
like also in vermont or new hampshire or
some somewhere close
but massive like a vermont two feet of
snow snowstorm okay
so i was a i was a fresh uh sophomore
and i used to sleep like you know
because like they couldn't have like
that many
like rooms or whatever like the
sophomores and freshmen would sleep
together
so the seniors came in with like a big
block of snow like somehow got into our
room i know they got like a room cart or
something like that
got into room in the middle of the night
and threw snow off the top of our
ceiling
and like landed on us like in the middle
of our hotel beds like crazy
they're like we're having a huge
snowball fight and the coach
our coach who's a great guy wanted to
like get involved like later on in the
snow fight and for some reason this kid
craig i don't know why the hell this kid
did this
he had got a bot he found a bottle
that was because he was freezing outside
like a full bottle of
of pepsi but it wasn't pepsi like
somebody had put water in and left it
outside
and had a frozen bottle of pepsi and we
were throwing snowballs and it was like
a fun
festive thing and we're throwing it in
each other snowballs even hitting the
coach snowballs
he you know top of his top speed
throws the frozen bottle of pepsi and
hits our coach
square in the head knocks him out
completely unconscious bleeding from his
head
in the middle of the field in vermont
what happens then
he wakes up the coach wakes up we have
to get him to the hospital
one of the stitch coaches called 9-1-1
we all were like why would you do that
he was like crazy did he get in trouble
suspended yeah he got suspended i think
for a couple of games but he was like
craig was like i just he was like we
were having a snowball fight so i just
threw
i just threw a nice pepsi and we were
like yeah that's the stupidest thing you
could have ever done you could have
killed the coach
and it was just one of those things
where i always remember like
just i mean could you imagine being
blasted in the head
with a frozen bottle of pepsi in a
snowball fight
no the amount of pain he was in was like
dude
and then he coached you could be a
vegetable the rest of your life no you
ever see like those old like it's almost
like cartoonish like in a war movie when
they have like thing over their eye like
a bandage over their head
like that's what he coached the next day
he looked like that
you know what terrifies me i just
watched on netflix that that documentary
social dilemma
where like pretty much like anything you
do online can be seen and then they take
your data and they sell it
to other places and i just feel like
anytime i go online
any website i go to some somebody's
going to take my data and sell it and
try to sell me products and there's just
absolutely nothing i can do and i know
there's no way that i could be helped
there's hardly any way around it right
now except for one way that i know
you might have hope hold on wait a
second you know a way
that i could go on a website and then my
data will not be sold to some other
website to sell me
products i really don't need yeah
expressvpn you never heard of it
expressvpn you had to download it you
could get an app for them on your phone
you could use it on your laptop it runs
in the background you don't even know
it's on
it protects you so your internet service
provider cannot track and sell your data
it's the only way to do it and actually
wired and cnet have rated expressvpn
the number one vpn out there because
there's a lot of them all right and this
is
this is a cut above the rest so if you
just go to expressvpn.com
promo code hey babe yeah you're going to
get three months free in a one-year
package
package
uno dos trace expressvpn.com slash hey
babe yeah
three months free on the one-year
package how did i even know about this
until now
you i don't know but just make sure you
get it right it's e x p
r e s s v n
hey babe to go and to learn more if you
won't even learn more you might want
more
people are going to have no idea what i
masturbate to anymore
right that's right thank you
expressvpn.com
hey babe chris yeah can you please tell
me
if you know of any place that i can go
if i want to get a little bit of
discreet counseling
off the top of my head the number one
place that i
i'm thinking of is betterhelp.com well
what's that i gotta go to some office
no which i gotta pay outrageous prices
no well i gotta wait two weeks to start
it nope
you can do it from the comfort of your
own home get a discreet
licensed counselor to hear whatever it
is you wanna talk about
for a great price if you put in the
promo code hey babe
you actually get 10 off the first month
10 off american go to
10 as far as i'm as far as i know i was
told 10
american money wherever you could be in
islamabad pakistan
right you're still going to get off 10
american for the first month by going to
better help
not health better help help calm
promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
10 off the first month it's just it's
the right thing to do
i can't believe i asked you that because
you had all the information i needed
sal a lot of times i'll see you doing
things
and i'll say why don't you just ask me
yeah and i'm happy that
on the podcast you decided to ask me
remember that time i was just putting a
straw into an orange and you were like
you should just pour yourself a glass of
juice
yes i should defer to you more often and
where do you think because
like i was just like you how many times
did you see me
putting the straw into the orange a lot
how did i learn
to start drinking orange juice
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com is where i learned that
you don't have to do that it's just in
the commercial
do they stick the straw in the orange
juice you know what it makes sense
because we could all
use betterhelp dot com
backslash hey babe for 10 off who
doesn't want 10 off the first month of
anything i want 10 off everything
they're getting me spoiled yeah better
help is getting me spoiled yeah i storm
into a room now the first thing i say is
i want 10 percent off i want to talk
where i am yeah if they come to back to
this show and they want to advertise
we love your fans so much they've been
they've been supporting betterhelp.com
hey babe so much we want to give you 20
off i'm going to say no it's going to
stay at 10.
that's right it just feels right you're
not trying to take advantage
it just feels right betterhelp.com hey
babe
okay so i'm sitting at home yesterday oh
yep pray tell me yeah all of a sudden i
get a knock at the door no
it's the postman post person yeah oh i i
say you say i have a package for you
okay
i said okay did you know who was from no
idea okay i opened up the package what
happened
i pull out a t-shirt i'm t-shirt i look
at the t-shirt yeah you know what
t-shirt says
ask me about my butthole what about your
butthole
it's clean the t-shirt said that
the t-shirt didn't say that you asked me
i said ask me about my own haul and you
said what about your butthole yeah and i
said it's clean but the t-shirts that
asked me about my butthole why
because if you were to ask me if you
would ask me a week ago about my
butthole i would say it's dirty
but right now it's what happened in the
time from last week to today
when i open up that package not only was
the t-shirt that said asked me about my
butthole there was also a device in
there
and it said hellotushi.com and i said
hellotushi.com yeah what's going on i
thought i never said goodbye to my tushy
yeah hello tushy.com
it's a it's a type of bidet you put it
on your existing toilet it sprays water
directly into your butthole
it saves me 80 on toilet paper
i'm telling you i went to go wipe my
butt yesterday after using this tushy
i said what the hell am i using you
doesn't even need the toilet paper for
me
because i for me i have the i'm the kind
of i have the kind of fecal matter where
i usually use
in one sitting i can use 80 of a roll of
toilet paper
that's how much fecal matter comes out
of my butt that is frustrating
it's frustrating yeah yeah instead do
you need electricity for this
no electricity so it's ready to go right
out of the package ready to go right out
of the package
literally if i went right if i was in
islamabad pakistan right now yeah
i could have my tushy don't even worry
about if there's electricity in the part
of town you're in worry about it you
don't have to worry about as long as you
got running water
your butthole can remain clean
some sort of revolution it's a
revolution how many people are doing
this
millions what they even have a new one
the the 3.0 model
and what if i already have a tushy from
in the past you upgrade to the 3.0 model
guess what you got to do why go to
hellotushy.com promo code hey babe
we're going to give something we're
gonna give a promo here yeah well yeah
actually go to hellotushy.com
hey babe you get 10 off plus free
shipping
hellotushy.com hey babe 10 off plus free
shipping
i tell you right now i give you my word
again this is my word
i'm not going to go another day without
blasting water up my ass not another
day i love listening to music as you
know and i love raycon earbuds i mean
anything ray j does
i'm a part of i'm chrissy raikons
chrissy ray jays i
genuinely can't get enough of these
earbuds here's the thing with them
there's no like dangling wires or
anything like that so
you just pop them right in here and it's
one size fits all i mean i have the
weirdest shaped ears and my ear holes
are like
so dumb but the raycons fit in perfectly
and smoothly
and every time i'm going for a jog or
just walking out of the house
to get some breathing room or you know
just like meditate a little bit they
just are always in my ear and they
always just feel cute and good
here's the thing raycon is offering 15
off all their products for all the
listeners 15
off raycon earbuds all you got to do is
go raycon.com
that's r-a-y-c-o-n dot-com slash
hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e and you're going
to get 15
of your entire raycon order so if you're
looking for headphones
that are awesome and don't have wires
and just fit right in your cute little
baby ears
raycon.com hey babe fifteen percent off
their qqq
what's up everybody february 25th to the
27th phoenix
arizona get the tickets christy
comedy.com i won't be selling these
shirts because these are philadelphia
but i am selling shirts in phoenix and
they're my face with a cactus on it
and they'll only be available in phoenix
arizona february 25th to the 27th house
of comedy phoenix
christcomedy.com tickets almost sold out
go get the tickets and then get a
t-shirt yes
can i tell you uh one time i was like uh
i want to say i was no more than seven
maybe about five or six and i used to
live in this apartment complex or other
apartment buildings
and i forget the girl's name at the time
i'm going all the way back to that but
there was this girl that was our
neighbor or who lived next to us and she
came around and we always used to hang
out
like in the in the grounds of the
apartment buildings
okay like they weren't really like the
regular streets okay so we had a little
bit of leeway as to where we can go what
we could do
you know because it was all private
property right so our family was like
just don't go off the property right so
growing up we had this really like big
piece of land that we would go all the
apartments and hang out
anyway i was a super little man and this
girl came and she had a bag of cookies
a little chocolate chip cookies in um in
a baggie uh what do you call it like a
ziploc
ziplock and she came around and she was
like oh who wants cookies
and she was like you could have a cookie
you could have a cookie
you could have a cookie and she's like
you can't have a cookie to me
and i was like okay like one can have a
cookie whatever and she's like i'm not
giving you a cookie she's just like
doing that kid thing and she's like kind
of being mean yeah and then so she
started to like
one thing led to another and i now she's
either she's walking away or she's not
near me she's a good
i'll call it 30 feet okay she's 30 feet
from me and she's saying something about
the cookies and i got upset with her
right
i'm six i pick up a rock and i throw it
at her
i don't think i'm hitting her she's 30
feet away i wanted to like
make her run away scare her just be like
show her that i was upset by just
throwing a rock in her direction right
also
either a rock in a direction move out of
the way yeah of course
my the rock that i threw from 30 feet
away a six-year-old to this other girl
that was probably about six years old
hit her in the ocular cavity what
knocked her
flat on her ass backwards screaming
dropped cookies everywhere
she starts screaming everybody was
there's like oh my god
all the kids run they go to ring her
bell ring their own parents bells ring
everybody's bells
i didn't know what to do i panicked and
i went
i just dropped whatever i was holding
ran into the building ran
all the way up the stairwells all the
way to the roof closed the door and i
was hiding out on the roof like i was in
the wire
right yeah i was just hiding hiding on
the roof of this building
shivering crying i didn't mean for it to
hit her it hit her i mean it hit her
in the eye and i'm looking over the
building and i see her lay down on the
floor still and i hear
now here all the parents screaming and
yelling and coming and they get her and
they pick her up and her eye is out to
hear swollen red
someone grabbed ice to give her an eye
she's holding ice on oh she's screaming
and crying where who dude
i hear my mom come out they're like yo
where is he he
ran up to the roof so now i hear all the
parents coming up and they i see him go
in the building and everyone's coming up
to the roof
and i'm like oh my god like i was so
nervous are you thinking maybe i'll just
jump
no all right no i knew that would
probably kill me
yeah but as a kid you don't you're not
thinking i knew i was gonna get in
trouble i didn't know what to do i'll
tell you what i was going to do when my
mom stopped me
i was going to jump there was no space
in between the buildings they were
connected
but i was going to jump on to the next
roof which we did when we played manhunt
i don't want to make it
right but like later on years later i
would i had so many roof hideouts like
that connected to other roofs but my mom
came up and she she goes let me go out
there first because i guess maybe she
anticipated that and she opened the door
and i was crying around she's like
listen to me
i guess she thought maybe i was cause
she's like because i was like like going
to and she goes no no don't go nowhere
she goes just come over here what
happened and i go i was like
i was like no no i didn't even mean like
i just was mad because she didn't give
me cookies i don't think i didn't mean i
swear to god
she's like just calm down it's gonna be
okay calm down she talked me out of it
and she brought me back downstairs and i
apologized and everybody took it in
stride
really is a real neatly bowed tied
ending to the whole story but i didn't
get nothing really bad happened
but i i l i took this girl out yeah and
then i retreated
i retreated to the skies yeah her whole
life changed because she has she was
down an eye
yeah i mean yeah i mean dude it was an
egg like a red egg like it was
yeah but i again i hit it right now just
like you coach and that's like one of
those things like with a throw
is like because like you don't play
after that like you never were able to
do anything
sports like that ever again right you
didn't play sports i played yeah i
played i played
i wasn't good more than a guy that
played sports no i played in uh
in grammar school i played baseball and
basketball right and then in high school
i played hockey
i was not good at any of them so i might
as well have not played sports but
yeah i mean what are the odds if you
asked me to do that again 30 feet think
of the velocity that stone picked up in
the air
and then it came down and landed on a
six-year-old girl's eye but was she
but but she must have had her back
towards you she so she also must have
turned around and looked up at the right
moment too right no she was like
she no she was facing us just drawing at
something about something
like this i remember just like throwing
it like i just
watched it it was like just a perfect
arch and it just was like it was just
perfect perfect and when it hit her i i
didn't know what to do
yeah i didn't i didn't want to i didn't
i wasn't even trying to hit her
on her foot yeah i was just throwing it
like i didn't think it would go
anywhere near her yeah right there right
there boom
that's like one time that's like one
time my um
it's just like things how like you know
like chance things happen
my aunt i was in the back seat my aunt
and uncle were in the front seat driving
with with with their daughter my cousin
i forgot we were coming back from a
doctor's appointment or something
and my uncle was eating i'll never
forget k you know kfc
he had a soda chicken whatever somebody
cut him off or
said something to him it was summertime
so he every he had the windows down the
car next to him had the windows down and
he took they were yelling i
don't know at what i really don't
remember but anyway he's driving he
takes to his wife give me the soda give
me the soda throws the soda at the car
like throws it towards the car at you
know that the car next them because
they're like screaming at him whatever
swear to god from my point of view and
this is what had to happen we were going
fast 30 miles an hour but i know this is
what happened because i saw it come out
the other way
the soda went through the other car and
landed and hit the car in the third lane
[Music]
it deserved it maybe we take that as a
drop how crazy is that
that's
so it's like it just literally like just
went through the trajectory
just went through the two open windows
crazy wow just wild things happen like
that sometimes
cue my buddies through some this guy
cursed him out of the light
and right before the light turned red he
took a huge soda that he had it was like
a
you know like a big gulp or something
and he just lofted it and it went right
in the guy
right through the window hit his console
exploded everywhere then q just peeled
out the relay the guy chased him for
blocks and blocks and blocked
you called me and he's like i got a guy
chasing me right to second
i didn't know what's gonna happen
exploded his car he's chasing you right
now
and he left me a message and i'm trying
to call him back and he's not answering
oh she got nervous yeah
he he at one point he had kept the
string of messages i left
because i got nervous because i thought
he was gonna like you know get and i'm
like you gotta call me back buddy i'm
like
i'm like just come to my house please i
have other beverages ah that sucks
because you imagine just exploded right
out of the console you ever get [ __ ] on
by
by a by a bird yes you've been [ __ ] on
by a bird
bird yeah i've been chilling by a bird
and i i've been [ __ ] on i had [ __ ] on um
actually when i went to uh
uh colin quinn the great colin quinn's
wedding yeah um two years ago wearing
this really nice blue suit
uh really really nice i know it was a
beautiful june wedding
the whole wedding i bird [ __ ] in the
back of my suit no [ __ ] yeah it wasn't
until the great robert kelly you know
he's like hey i know you think you look
good in that suit whatever
[ __ ] on your nuts you know i was
thinking about it because my dad i
remember one time we go into the mall
and my dad we had a mazda626 and he had
the sunroof open
and we parked the car and as soon as he
parked the car he turned and smiled and
bird [ __ ] right on his head
to the sunroof and he just he just
looked at me turned started the
controversy
i've had birds [ __ ] on me a couple times
though yeah they say it's good luck but
that's they're lying yeah she's trying
to make you feel is it good luck yeah no
it's just trying to make you feel better
what does it mean let's say
um bird poop they just say they just say
that it's good luck but
you know it's not it's not good luck at
all it's just something that's you know
like the atlanta is more set like when
it rains on your wedding day it's like
it's not this is just a heart they're
trying their life yeah
you know the worst feeling in the world
is stepping in [ __ ] and then it gets
into all the crevices of like
the buddha sneaky you're wearing yeah
and even if you take a stick or rub it
it just doesn't come out and you have to
walk around all day with that in your
shoe and then when you get home what do
you do
what when it was clean you got to go
right in you got to blast it out
you can't put it in your closet one of
jasmine's um uh grandmother
two years ago middle of midtown
manhattan like lit birth control
you know four um um
uh what uh one of her uh her grandmother
you know has been in america
you know for 20 years yeah we were in uh
you know new york city whatever
steps and [ __ ] like you know wearing
shoes it was the summer time
steps and [ __ ] just goes oh you know
whatever in spanish like
stepped in dog poop whatever ideas me oh
you know hey macarena whatever she's
i i could um yeah she says yeah yeah lit
we're on like you know 36th street in
lexington avenue
just takes both of our shoes off and
proceeds to keep like literally takes
both of her shoes off
just leaves him there by the tree and we
keep walking throughout the city and
and you know she's saying like she's
pissed or whatever yeah she wouldn't we
we finally got her shoes but it wasn't
it was like 10 blocks her just walking
she just left her shoes
she's like this is what we do in puerto
rico if you step and [ __ ] well no that's
she's like i just walk around you know
i'm from puerto rico we've been going
around barefoot
wow just walking through the new york
city street i'm not a barefoot guy on
concrete
you ever do that it's hot it's not only
that but like you ever have to like run
out to the car on the sidewalk
and you go barefoot and there's like
rocks and glass and you just kind of
gotta walk it like yours
you ever walk on hot coals no you have
no
we should do it i almost patreon.com
patreon only
i almost did it once and i heard that it
is is of is
is like it's you can't get burned
for some reason i don't know if that's
true or not because it's like i think
it's like people think that it's bad but
actually ultimately it maybe it takes a
second
for the heat to transfer and that you
could walk in it well that's why tony
robbins has people walk it right all the
time you know that
at the end of his seminars everybody
walks hot coals because it's really not
hot
maybe it is i don't know but i thought
anyone could do it like
tony robbins by the way every morning of
his life jumps in a freezing cold
pool and that's how he wakes his body up
he said you have to do that
yeah can you see if can anyone walk on
hot coals anybody have a bigger
head than tony robbins how much is tony
robbins worth
okay google tony robbins net worth i'm
gonna guess right now 155 million
dollars yeah i'm gonna guess more than
that
okay i'm gonna guess 300 million 500
million dollars 500 million
well we don't know this is real okay
what is the perfect purpose of walking
on hot coals fire walking
has been practiced by many people and
cultures in all parts of the world with
the earliest known reference dating back
to the iron age india
circa 1200 bc it is often used as rite
of passage
as a test of an individual strength of
courage or in religion but
what's the fun can we do can anyone do
it what's this what's the secret to
walking on hot coals right there pippy
what's because this is interesting basic
physical principle beyond firewalking is
the same that allows an egg to boil in a
paper cup and place the top red hot
coals
the boiling water keeps the cup at 212
degrees fahrenheit
cooler than paper's burning point what i
don't understand that i don't understand
that well i'm a stupid
kid i don't understand it either so what
does that make me a stupid
friend i don't know dude without it's
they said it's possible wood is a lousy
conductor there has to be a way that
tony robbins is
yeah he can't just bring people the
power of your mind yeah people are
paying like three grand to go see him
and he can't just be throwing them into
the flames no he can't do that so he has
to know that they're able to do it
coal doesn't conduct heat well so as
long as it burns no hotter
than 1000 degrees fahrenheit and you
walk across it quickly enough
you should arrive safely at the finish
line without so much as a blister
we should do it tony robbins uh only
three three times
three times you've met tony robbins no
i'm just like i just
i do know his right hand and when i say
right hand
i know his right hand right uh a
gentleman i won't i won't name him
specifically but he
was james my buddy he was my buddy's
college roommate
and it is still to this day his right
hand to this day yeah yeah
he goes all with him behind that he does
all that stuff with him he helps run the
seminars and stuff do you think
how long do you think it would take you
500 million half a billion how do you
think it would take you to count to
a million
let me think about this that's that's a
really that's a really tough question
well let's call it 10
a hundred
a thousand i wanna say
i'm really trying to give you a a real
guess i just i wanna say
i i i think i'm miscalculating this
wrong hold on 60 goes into
10 605 600 and then
like i don't know
80 hours at one number per second
with no breaks at all for any reason
including sleep or anything
to count to a million it would take 11
days
13 hours 46 minutes and 40 seconds holy
[ __ ] to count from one to a million
with no breaks at all for any reason and
the number a second
11 days 11 days without
no so in real i thought i was
overshooting it at 80 hours
realistically let's say you did an eight
hour work week uh
you know 40 hour work week just counting
out loud that was your job for eight
hours
right it probably would take two months
or something to count to a minute wow
wait a minute so then it's probably not
even possible
count to a billion a billion it can't be
possible can't be possible okay cause
it's
is it a billion a million millions
finally no is it a billion million
millions it is
a thousand millions but a thousand
million thirty one years two thousand
millions
no breaks 31 years
what no break sal can you count to a
billion in your lifetime
finally we end up with an approximate of
31 years 251 days seven hours within 40
seconds
in short if you count it to a billion
you better start now
you you could have started counting to a
billion when you were born and you would
have finished three years ago three
years ago four years ago
well five years ago wow i wonder what
the most announcements have accounted to
what is this a waste of time what's the
most anyone's ever counted to out
i'm going to say i'm going to say uh i'm
going to say
two and a half million one million
highest number of singularities ever
count is
two is a nice even one million harper
still holds a record for the highest
number counted out loud by one person
he counted for about 16 hours every day
without taking a day off leaving his
apartment or even shaving
oh my god this guy was doing quarantine
before quarantine really
this guy so so that's the most anyone's
ever counted to out loud jeremy harper
that's what they say jeremy harper he
live streamed it
took him 89 days imagine you watching
that whole life 89 days of 16
hours a day that the other thing said 13
i mean that's oh you know why because
because because think about this when
you're going
999 991 999
900 like he's not just going one did you
advise they're not dealing with advice
he's counting the actual numbers yeah so
it takes a while
so this this guy 89 days
16 hours a day so he was only sleeping
he was counting for 89 days straight and
only to going to sleep
what does he get from that besides
losing 89 days of his life yeah did he
make any
his million count website and form were
taken down months later
so he did all this work and then they
took it down why
he began on june 18 2007 and finished on
september 14th
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard he raised ten thousand dollars for
charity i mean it's such a ten thousand
he could have done more asking
individual people for a dollar each i
mean we gotta get this guy on the
podcast
i wanna know all about it i wanna know
all about it i want to know all about
this guy i mean i'm sure we i'm sure
he's got i mean he's
he listens birmingham and works for
ready mix
and birmingham mountain radio why why
would you do that
is he fat why jeremy if you're watching
and we know that you are
who's counted to 100 the fastest i just
saw that went back somebody said it's
just counted to 100 the fastest
well that's a good bet you want to try
that yeah somebody said who counted
i'm going to say who counts to 100 the
fastest i think somebody probably
wait a second that's under one minute
49 seconds
from 1 to 149.76 seconds
while standing straight on his father's
shoulders what was the point of that
is the kid is four years old he holds
the record for counting to a hundred
does he have to stand on his father's
shoulders though
i mean right now we're gonna break his
record right now to show this kid what's
up
this kid is about four years old he's
balancing his body on his
on his pop shoulders
i'll wreck this kid
fastest time to count from one to 100
while standing straight on someone's
shoulders that's what it is let's break
his record right now let's do it right
now right now can you support me can i
support you
we'll break his record right now we'll
email him right now we'll have everybody
tweet at him because
i'm gonna shatter it also how about what
if i sit on your shoulders
yeah just sit on my shoulders right now
and count to 100 as long as we time it
it's over 49 seconds
we're shattering this kid's recording
everybody right now let's do it all
right
we are not even going to practice don't
even don't even practice
but listen to me don't screw this up
just just make sure your addiction is
good you know don't don't don't don't
don't cheat words because i don't want
to be cold
i don't want to be you're doing it or
i'm doing it oh i thought you were doing
it
because you're standing on my shoulders
okay i'll do it i'm going to time you
though okay all right
and i'll do it in the indian accent as
well what's this gentleman's name
because i want to tell him right now
it's about to get shattered
now you're going to say 21 you're going
to say every every word
and you've got to beat one to 100 you've
got to be 49.76 seconds
ready this kid doesn't know what's his
skin's yes i'm when i hit start ready
okay
one two three go one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
seventeen eighteen nineteen twenty
twenty one twenty two
twenty three twenty four twenty five
twenty six twenty seven twenty eight
twenty nine thirty
thirty one thirty two thirty three
thirty four thirty five thirty six
thirty 36 37 38 39 40
41 42 43 44 45 46 47 48 49 50. 51 52 53
54 55 867
3859 60 61 62 63 64
566 67 68 69 70 71 72 73 74 75
76 77 78 79 80 81 82 83 84 85 86
87 88 89 90 91 92 93 94 96 97 98 99
oh 100 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 99 100.
suck it to cash 45
19. you beat him by two seconds and i
skipped 95 and i
i t bagged you and i just farted
he's been walking around on his high
horse for too long that's what it is
name one podcast that does guinness book
world records like we do it guinness
if you're watching i'm legitimate nailed
that nailed that you see that
and that my kids is how you take a bad
day on the calorie fitness pal app
and you burn off some cows last minute
that's it
i legit out of breath how about this do
i have covered
they say one of the symptoms that people
don't really know a lot is that you uh
you get out of breath count to andre uh
you holy smokes we did it and i missed
enough
and you miss imagine if you didn't flub
you you would have really
what did i miss again i just 95 i think
you said i think you missed 95.
it's harder than you think i know we
could play it back but you did i that's
why i didn't want i didn't want to i
didn't want to get like disqualified
from from the beginning listen even with
the flub i mean i i
15 seconds i shaved off the kid yeah no
no he did it in 47 no
i mean what was his 49.76
so you beat him by four handily
4.8 seconds and i think i i think my
technique wasn't good because i was
going 49.
uh what is his name i want to get it
right it was it dake
i can't read that sorry
should we say 49.7
[Music]
should we send dakar sudri and his
family just to let them know that we're
in business some some animal poop yeah
or serotonin
saratoga peanut butter saratoga peanut
butter yeah
yeah the kid's a cute kid he did it and
you know by the way he only did it
november 2000 uh 2020. wow so this isn't
he's still that age and this isn't old
you you shattered
a record and it's loose yeah
well hold on here we go the fastest time
to type the alphabet it's
what to type the alphabet is 3.3 seconds
that one i can't even i mean yeah oh
yeah
that's crazy i don't even understand so
just going like
a b c d e g as in yeah i don't know
wow that felt good that felt nice to go
to counter we came in here just
you know you and you left here a world
record holder
i left your world record holder and that
felt good and i did the whole thing
now i'm sorry i'm just gonna get it
no
and yeah and right on the back of your
neck teabagged yeah i'm sorry about that
but you know there's nothing we could
really do no
but i will tell you like i was getting i
was like i knew i don't know if you knew
this but
i was trying to do a little bit of like
projection and you were at one point
you were i mean you were gonna make you
this kid would have should crawl into a
hole
he should dig a hole and crawl into it
like a goddamn ostrich because he should
be embarrassed
yeah no because you were about to if you
didn't flub you would have had it at
like 30 something
the flub is one of those things where
it's like i kind of felt like i was
gonna shatter the record
and i just got like so nervous and it
was kind of like my own
like hang-ups about myself like i think
i intentionally with it because i have a
fear of success
i think i did that on purpose and i
flipped on purpose i noticed one thing
you were doing but i couldn't
stop you because you can't stop someone
in motion right but you were doing like
a little fun thing at the end of each uh
at the end of the week
but that is costing you valuable second
it is
because i just thought when we're
getting into a new 10
you know yeah like i i want to sound off
right right
right so yeah i uh i i i felt good yet
so i
now i mean if the guinness book of world
records doesn't i mean i have to give me
give us
something it's literally it's real this
is recorded
i think they have to have a rep present
and i will tell you this right now
we should we should we should get on the
podcast we should get a rep down here we
should break that record
100 i'll do that register for an account
receive an email i
i did hear though that the guinness book
of world records is really like um
you know like you pay them for them to
come record your record you know so it's
not like right i don't know if it's
independent they i think they
the people that are in it have to pay to
be in it is that right so it's really
not that big of a deal but honestly
patreon seriously if we want if we want
to shadow this record i go right to the
patreon i'm down to do that dude are we
making a running list of what
what will be on the patreon when he
writes it down all right the kid pimp
writes it down
okay because i don't remember do you
think there's a record for longest
podcast
they're happy oh i bet you there's a
stand-up show it's like i
think it's 24 hours right yeah i went
and saw that guy do that
it was happening when i was at like it
was like jfl or something somebody was
doing it and we passed by and looked at
it watched
mike russell did a 36-hour non-stop
podcast
in 2016. that is i mean i don't even
i mean do we do try to break that what
could you possibly even be talking about
how how how do you do it
oh 80 hours i was in nashville it was in
nashville yeah
i was there for the wild west comedy
festival right and you saw it happening
well oh no it was the longest show they
asked us to be part of it
that's what it was oh man i wonder if i
was i can't remember
i know that sounds wild but i did so
many spots that week
no it was five it was six years ago i
did so many spots that week
and i know people like i might do it and
i i don't remember if i did it or if i
just went and watched
i don't remember i guess i would be on
there if they they wrote it i would be
home
i'm a fan of even in any form of
entertainment
hour hour and a half tops you get in you
get out that's what i think people like
the most
i'm not but you but you know you're
different than me you can sit and really
enjoy something i've been to shows with
you
the magic show we went to where it's two
hours and you're invested and you
you're a guy who's in the moment a lot
i'm a guy who i can't really stay
focused for that long on anything but
you're you're do you meditate if it's
good
uh i nah i i i mean i use the headspace
app
right sponsor sponsor uh once we get the
ad read
yeah we're gonna do it that's right oh
we haven't done that yet
oh cut it out okay oh well no no keep it
no there it's their sponsor for us still
oh god bless them
uh yeah no i i i i did it for a while
meditation but i don't do it anymore but
i will tell you if the show's good i i
like it i'll stay yeah
yeah i'll stay yeah cause i i'm trying
to work on that i'm trying to like
meditate more do like deep breathing i'm
trying to like really stay focused
on the present moment and not think
about you know ten days ahead of me but
it's the only way to live you know in
the moment yeah now at cartola yeah
it's at cartel oh is that a cartolay i
don't know
i don't know i listen to his podcast
that he does with oprah you ever listen
to that one about his
oprah he wrote a new book eckhart tolle
and then oprah read it and loved it so
much
that that she did a podcast with him
where he explains the book
and it was literally the most profound
podcast i've ever seen in my life and
now i've forgotten
what the name of the book even was and
anything that was ever told to me
in the book by eckhart tolle oh is that
right i listened to the power of now on
audiobook and i couldn't get through it
that's the name of the book put me
straight to bed
too much he was taught he was he has a
soothing voice
yeah and he's just like he said by the
way in his book i think it's power now
with the next book after that
that when he realized he had this
revelation about himself that he
was so in the moment and so in one with
now that he was homeless for two years
and that he was shivering and he was
laughing and in ecstasy and he said he
was homeless sleeping on a park bench
for two years
because he was so in the moment even
though he had money and a family he said
that
that's insane yeah his family stayed
with him yeah he has children he just
stayed homeless
that's what it is a new earth awakening
eckhart tolle new earth just put
homeless for two years and oprah was
like that can't be true and he was like
it is oprah
i want to know about eckhart a time as a
homeless man
you know he said he was homeless he said
it's been five years homeless that's
insane
he spent every day in a park on a bench
in london but he was not homeless he
just wasn't doing anything towards his
career at the time
he was doing a podcast i mean that's the
power now right there
yeah what can you do let me tell you
something when you were uh saying those
numbers
your voice uh it felt like you were
really in the
in the moment i was in the moment you
you had a very cheery voice i think you
were
were you enjoying it i had a really good
time there was something about you how
you were just like
there was pride in it yeah you were
doing it i think that you had a handle
on it and then you
every time you were like 39 40. like it
just was very like it felt
joyous it was one of those things where
genuinely like genuinely i was doing
that and i was up
at maybe like number you know 38 39 40.
i was like i wish my family was here to
see this
i was thinking like i would genuinely
was like one day when we're old and
great we'll talk about the day you
shattered this kid's recording
this kid's record and it's unfortunate
because you know i know he thought he
was the record holding and shouted him
he's going to get saratoga peanut butter
yeah the whole shoot your family's going
to get saratoga peanut butter yeah but
the record's broken and i have it now
yeah that's it that's just and that's
and and honestly if someone if someone
wants to smoke
i mean send us videos tag it what can we
hashtag this
people can send us videos of them
sitting on their friend's shoulders
timing themselves counting to a hundred
you gotta beat 40 what did i say
45 45.19 but with a 95 with a flub at
95.
yeah we flubbed but okay if you think
that you could sit on your friend's
shoulders
and count to 100 in under 45.19 seconds
send us the video just hashtag it hey
babe guinness book
hey babe guinness book perfect hey babe
guinness book
go do that follow us subscribe subscribe
to the podcast hey babe
um we're doing a lot subscribe to the
podcast taste buds i mean we're doing a
lot of fun things from this freaking
couch
how about this babe whoever will put it
we'll put a um
we'll put a deadline on it whoever holds
the record
gets a free patreon membership wow there
you go
whoever the fans holds the record
because here's the thing and you get a
free patreon membership and i'm going to
say this i'm going to say it arrogantly
you're not going to beat my number so
whichever the one out of the best people
who submit a thing
but if you think you're going to get
past 45 19 yeah it's not happening no
that's pretty solid just so you know
yeah and so you'll win it and
patreon just one other thing patreon
does not exist yet
we started it in the beginning we
realized we wanted to retool that model
and put out everything
all the videos out for free now we're
deciding what's going to be the
powerhouse
punch when we drop the patreon it'll be
exclusive merch
for patreon members only i believe that
we'll have regular merch too yeah i
think the patreon's got to get some
merch exclusively
all the things you've been talking about
we're making a list of the fish funeral
yes you know the guinness book all that
stuff on the patreon
and it doesn't exist yet but it's coming
out and
and by the way when you join our patreon
which some people have done already and
we're letting you know that's on you
we've refunded everyone
and that's not even going to be the
patriot there's a new patreon that we're
creating that's not even the one yet so
get off that well you don't have to get
off that one you can do what you'd like
but there will be nothing going up onto
that patreon
so we're starting a new patreon yes and
that patreon
which we will we're going to make soon
and announce soon will have exclusive
content that is only on patreon and will
not be on youtube
or twitter or itunes or anywhere else
but patreon so
join that family we're going to release
it very soon
there you go folks and if you want to
see us in your city
well you're well you could see sally all
the time on true tv he'll tell you about
that me christy comedy.com
atlantic city phoenix arizona red bank
new jersey
coming at you christy comedy.com for
tickets also patreon.com
christy comedy for me and my podcast
christy chaos which you can catch
every tuesday and you know i love you
that's it
text me at 718-260-6619 it's an app
called community
i can't text everyone back but i see all
your messages i text you back some
some of you and i i release everything
there before i release it on social
media
yolanda vega yolanda vega
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings
babe don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe